ya hemos hablado sobre las reacciones s
n 1 s n 2 el 1 y el 2
ahora vamos a identificar cuando ocurren
la clave está en observar la estructura
del alumno de alquilo para los saludos
de alquilo primarios no ocurren todas
estas reacciones por ejemplo las
reacciones sn 1 y 1 no pueden ocurrir
porque en estas reacciones se forma un
carbó catión primario y un kart vocación
primario no es estable así que para los
saludos de alquilo primarios solo se
pueden llevar a cabo reacciones del tipo
s n 2 o 2 y las reacciones s n 2 son más
favorecidas veamos un ejemplo de esto
aquí tenemos al bromo etano y lo hacemos
reaccionar con hidróxido de sodio
cuáles son nuestros productos primero
identifiquemos al núcleo filo en este
caso
el núcleo filo es el año en hidróxido
clasificamos a la unión hidróxido como
tiene una carga forma negativa es un
núcleo filo fuerte como vimos en vídeos
anteriores los núcleos y los fuertes
favorecen las reacciones por la vía sn 2
ya que estas reacciones necesitan núcleo
filos fuertes y si pensamos en el
hidróxido como una base es una base
fuerte se favorece el mecanismo por la
vía 2 entonces entre la reacción sn dos
nietos la sn 2 ocurre más rápido para
este alumno de alquilo primario s n 2
siguiendo el mecanismo para esta
reacción por la vía sn 2
sabemos que el ataque núcleo físico
ocurre al mismo tiempo que estos
electrones se van con el bromo y
finalmente se forma etanol como nuestro
producto
este es el producto en mayor cantidad se
obtiene por la vía sn 2 y por la vía 2
obtendríamos el producto menor hagamos
otro nuevamente tenemos al bromo etano y
esta vez lo hacemos reaccionar con
termot óxido de potasio k más y elaño
net óxido a la izquierda identifiquemos
primero a nuestro núcleo filo claro es
el alcohol sido en el vídeo anterior
dijimos que los anones al cocido se
consideran núcleo filos fuertes sin
embargo este es un núcleo filo muy
voluminoso estos grupos metilo
disminuyen la núcleo phil y that como
hay dificultades terika entonces es un
núcleo filo débil no favorecerá la
reacción sn 2 porque las sn dos
necesitan núcleo filos fuertes sin
obstáculos
ahora pensemos en la base ciudad de
nuestra unión al óxido sabemos que es
una base fuerte las bases fuertes
favorecen las reacciones de eliminación
entonces será la reacción de dos un
mecanismo concertado no se favoreció la
reacción sn dos por la dificultades
teórica que hace que el núcleo filo sea
débil así que llevaremos a cabo la
reacción por la vía de dos por esa vía
se forma un al que no como éste el
alcohol sido tomar a un protón y dejar a
los electrones que formarán el doble
enlace y el bromo se va así nos queda el
producto entonces una luro de alquilo
primario podrá reaccionar por la vía es
n 2 o 2
sn 2 será la más favorecida a menos de
que se tenga un núcleo filo débil y una
base fuerte para ese caso la base toma
el control y reacciona por la vía del
mecanismo de dos ahora echemos un
vistazo a los saludos de alquilo
terciarios los saludos de alquilo
primarios son los más fáciles todo lo
que tienen que hacer es elegir entre s n
2 y el 2 después siguen los saludos de
alquilo terciarios nuevamente pondré
todas las posibilidades sn 1 s n 2 el 1
y el 2 bueno las reacciones sn 2 no
ocurren con alumnos de alquilo
terciarios porque para un mecanismo por
la vía sn 2 se necesita baja dificultad
histérica y un alumno de alquilo
terciario tiene mucha dificultad
histérica por
las reacciones sn 2 no ocurren con un
alumno de alquilo terciario pero aún
podemos elegir entre la s n 1 y 1 o 2
las reacciones de eliminación son más
favorecidas cuando se tiene un alumno de
alquilo terciario y si tenemos una base
fuerte entonces dará una reacción de
eliminación veamos un ejemplo de un
alumno de alquilo terciario aquí tenemos
al cloruro de éter butilo y lo hacemos
reaccionar con hidróxido de potasio
muy bien una vez más identifiquemos
primero al núcleo filo aquí está el año
en hidróxido será el núcleo filo sabemos
que es un núcleo filo fuerte lo que me
hace pensar en la reacción sn 2
pero como esa reacción no es posible
aquí entonces nos enfocamos en la base
sabemos que el hidróxido es una base
fuerte lo que me lleva al mecanismo 2 ya
sabíamos que la eliminación es
favorecida cuando tenemos una base
fuerte esta reacción no ocurre en un
mecanismo por la vía de 2 aquí no
importa la dificultad estética por aquí
tenemos un protón y el hidróxido actuará
como una base tomará al protón y estos
electrones se moverán hacia acá al mismo
tiempo que estos electrones se van junto
con el cloro así se forma un al que no
como nuestro producto
no importa la dificultad estética y si
tenemos una base fuerte entonces
ocurrirá una reacción de eliminación
veamos otra reacción nuevamente pondré
al cloruro de termo tilo y esta vez lo
haremos reaccionar con agua el agua es
nuestro posible núcleo filo por este par
de electrones libres es una reacción de
sol bolt isis ahora como clasificamos al
agua
bueno el agua puede actuar como un
núcleo filo pero es un núcleo filo débil
un núcleo filo débil da la posibilidad
de un mecanismo por la vía es n 1 y qué
pasa con el agua como base bueno el agua
también puede actuar como una base pero
no reacciona muy bien porque es una base
débil podría ser el mecanismo e1
entonces ya pensamos en el mecanismo es
n 1 y el 1 en ambos casos se da la
formación de un kart vocación en el
primer paso estos electrones se irán
junto con el cloro y nos queda un kart
vocación terciario un kart vocación
terciario es muy estable y ahora tenemos
dos posibilidades
una es el mecanismo por la vía s n 1 y
la otra por la vía y 1 en un mecanismo
sn 1 un par de electrones libres del
átomo de oxígeno que actúa como núcleo
filo ataca al kart vocación y después de
que se pierde un protón se forma el ter
butanol este es el posible producto por
sn 1
el otro posible producto se forma cuando
el agua actúa como una base débil toma
un protón y nos queda un al que no ahí
está
así que obtenemos dos productos uno por
la vía sn uno y el otro por la vía y uno
y hemos visto que para los alumnos de
alquilo terciarios hay tres
posibilidades
recuerden observar primero la estructura
de salud o de alquilo y después tomen en
cuenta al núcleo filo clasificarlo como
fuerte
y lo mismo para el que actúa como base
espero que con estas claves puedan
obtener sus productos a temperaturas
altas se favorece la reacción de uno
entonces si aumentamos la temperatura
podemos obtener más de un producto por
la vía y uno en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos de los saludos de alc y los
secundarios y podrán ver que es un poco
más difícil que los primarios y los
terciarios